and it kind of just puts us in the same  predicament where it's like through our  20s like this this is what the guys are  complaining about it's like okay through  our 20s we're gonna sleep around with  the the rappers the entertainers and  maybe like you know most girls I I would  say I know the manosphere says  differently don't don't have access to  the guys you would access to right but  it could be like the town rapper the  town like whatever whatever it was right  yeah and those guys will never commit  and if they do commit they'll probably  cheat and then we come at 30 and say  take me now maybe with a kid from  someone yeah and it's like the guy comes  in and feels like he's like settled for  because the guys he really wanted were  in your 20s  and it's kind of like what you're saying  is kind of reiterating this because you  just said now like you don't have the  guys you want in your DMs anymore